this morning we're bringing you the last
installment for now of our series
kindness 101 with steve hartman he and
his kids have been sharing stories that
are built around themes of kindness and
character
in the people who've mastered those
qualities on this memorial day the
lesson is respect steve and his kids
introduce us to a student making it his
duty to honor veterans who finish their
own missions nearly 80 years ago
good morning you all know this girl hi
i'm meryl hartman meryl can you please
put up our word for the day respect
and emmett over at the dictionary desk
can you please define this word respect
is a feeling of appreciation for one's
achievements or abilities
yeah respect is the best way to tell
someone he or she matters
a lot of people respect firefighters or
teachers a lot of kids respect their
parents
in some cases
never let a joke go untold
fortunately for me respect isn't just
about what you say it's about what you
do what you do to show someone they are
important and valued
best example i have is this story pulled
from our library and presented today
with all due respect
rishi sharma has always been into
superheroes
the real kind that's why as a junior in
high school he made it his mission to
meet as many world war ii combat
veterans as possible i ditched so many
days of high school to go do an
interview you were skipping school to go
interview vets yeah i started riding my
bike to the local senior home then i
started driving
it became a daily undertaking every
single day he would drive all over
southern california i had a lot of
missions interviewing guys like marine
tank commander ernie eisley they were
going to make a big camp there attack us
at night
rishi talks to the men for hours wow
then gives the recordings to their
families
he says he does it because time is short
we're losing more than 200 world war ii
vets every day
it's amazing how much history and
knowledge is encased in each one of
these individuals and how much is lost
when one of them dies without sharing
their story
at this point i should tell you rishi
doesn't come from a military family
his parents immigrated here from india
and yet he cares as much about our
greatest generation as any young man
i've ever met
my name is reishi sharma in addition to
his in-person interviews he was
telephoning at least five world war ii
vets a day just to thank them for their
service and sacrifice it means a great
deal to me that you are willing to
endure all of that so that i could be
here today well thank you very much
after this story first aired rishi
raised money to expand his mission to
visit vets across the country learning
about their stories and their scars
those that have healed
and those that will never who is that
this is my brother jack and he died in
my arms on the battlefield
nice to know as long as there are world
war ii veterans willing to talk
there will be at least one young man
willing to listen you mean a lot to me
that was five years ago did he stick to
his plan
well let's find out hello rishi hi how
are you guys we're great
are you still traveling the country
visiting veterans yeah i've just
interviewed just over 1400 world war ii
veterans now and i'm still doing
interviews almost every day across the
u.s and canada the uk and australia and
you do all this with donations
yeah i have a non-profit organization
called remember world war ii dot org and
i'm gonna be interviewing world war two
veterans every day until there are none
what makes you so interested in these
world world two veterans
i think that if we preserve the stories
of the greatest generation we will
inspire future generations to live up to
their standards
and to uphold the values that over 420
000 americans gave their entire lives up
for
when you respect these vets as you do
what do you think they get out of the
process
i think it gives them a sense of uh
worth to tell them that their
contributions still hold value and that
they certainly will never be forgotten
i think you just defined respect
perfectly we're very grateful for you
thank you thank you guys by showing
those vets such respect
such reverence
rishi has satisfied a need we all have
to know we matter
thanks for watching and don't forget to
stay kind
gotta love that right
i i'm just amazed that you know people
that he goes back to visit are still
doing the things
that he showcased in his pieces and
they've taken it up a notch such an
important work to make sure that these
veteran stories can be chronicled
while they're still here to tell them
yeah and a good reminder for us today on
memorial day to thank all the men and
women who served our country
today and what an incredible
man and to see him transform and and to
see him physically
with a mustache with a haircut
remember remember world war ii dot org
that's the website everybody should go
take a look